Godfrey Blum joins us now from Hull what
did you mean by the term Bongo Bongo
land mr. Blum I mean undemocratic
dictatorships across the world who
accept aid with absolutely no question
of an audit trail they're the people I'm
getting at and the point I was making is
very important 1 billion pounds a month
going away in overseas aid without an
audit trail with 40% of that goes to the
EU who have to signed off their accounts
now for 18 years
it's an intern it's a national disgrace
when we're cutting back our hospitals
our police and I've got in a very poor
constituency here I've got people
waiting for cancer treatment dialysis
machines and we're giving this money
away it's absolutely disgraceful there
is an important debate to be had about
international aid there are many who
will agree with your views there are
others who will disagree but that isn't
the point of this today is that it is
your use of the term bongo bongo line
which is a derogatory expression it is
racist language that may be in the
opinion of Guardian newspaper but it is
not in the newspaper I think the
majority of people would say that is
racist language no they wouldn't no they
wouldn't they might in your Westminster
bubble your little world of of
Westminster but out here in Howe and
Yorkshire where we tell it like it is
that's not they don't feel it's racist
at all and I have noticed mister does it
Robert returns how possibly be getting
you're safe how can you get yourself
into such a state about us something
which doesn't even exist there is no
such country so how can anybody be
offended so why did you use the term
then if there's no such country what
were you trying to achieve it is a
derogatory term that implies drum
banging natives doesn't it well I was
trying to portray the view that we do
not have a proper audit trail of where
our money goes and the only people that
seem to be upset about the use of
this expression are the media people not
ordinary people out here but party is
obsessed about the use of the expression
mr. bloom isn't it because you have been
asked not to use it again
my my boss died your Faraj has asked me
not to use it again and I promised him
that I won't and if it upsets my boss
obviously I don't want to do it and I
don't intend to use the term again but
what is good what is good now I've
turned and turned it this into a
national debate on where 1 billion
pounds worth of our money goes every
month and if I have achieved I think
I've done my country some good I don't
think that is what we're debating I
think we're debating the use of the term
here are your party called for the
suspension of an Italian MEP after he
used the same term Bongo Bongo in a
tirade against Italy's first batt
Minister you called for his suspension
on those grounds do you think you should
be says no you're quite wrong quite
wrong no you're wrong madam you're wrong
that was a piece of personal abuse aimed
at an individual this wasn't this was a
40-minute speech which had no it's all
in this why don't you get back to the
real argument of where our 1 billion a
month goes why is it that you are
incapable of debating what everybody
wants debated where does our money go
f-16s for Pakistan we've just seen
Argentina buy 40 Maria mirages aircraft
from Spain
that's another recipient of you EU aid
our money why don't we all discuss what
people are really wanting to discuss
instead of getting hiked up on this
silly nonsense let's talk about the real
debate please
I'm my apologies but actually you are
the one who used the term Bongo Bongo
and that is why this story is in the
headlines today no it isn't the reason
it's in the headlines is people are fed
up with their money going and they don't
know where it's going 1 billion pounds a
month that's what my all morning I've
been getting support thousands of texts
and emails about that not about the use
of the term at all so you're quite wrong
I don't believe that this would have
been in the headlines if you had just
had a debate about it about the use of
international aid it is
use of the term Bongo Bongo do you
regret using that term no because we've
actually start the national debate we've
started if you're right if you're right
we wouldn't be having a national debate
would we on overseas aid and now we're
having it it would be disingenuous of me
to regret having said it having got this
debate going again was it deliberate was
it all about publicity and from winning
votes no it was five fight you know this
speech is five weeks old in open arena
in open forum five weeks ago in
Birmingham this speech was made all of a
sudden the Guardian have got themselves
all got their knickers in a twist about
it but I'd like to say again let's talk
about the real issues and you should be
talking about that sky you have a
responsibility Sky Television to talk
about the real issues not this sort of
tabloid nonsense do you
do you regret using that term and do you
apologize to those who have offended by
using that term this boom if you check
your tape you'll see you've already
asked me that question to those of
course depends I won't use it again okay
thank you very much to whom if I called
stuffins
okay Godfrey PM thank you